Speaker 1: Hey, you know, I am I am starting
to think.
That when Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green
apologized for comparing things to the Holocaust,
it may not have been a completely sincere
apology because she is yet again saying that
things Joe Biden is doing are like the Nazis.
The Business Insider is reporting Margery
Taylor Greene compares Biden's vaccine push
to Nazis weeks after apologizing for comparing
mass mandates to the Holocaust.
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green compared
Biden's vaccination push to the Nazi brownshirts.
This came weeks after she apologized for comparing
other covid-19 guidelines to the Nazis.
That was when she said Nancy Pelosi saying
you have to wear masks on the House floor.
Is is is I guess, like, you know, how the
Jews were treated by Nazis.
Green has a history of promoting anti-Semitic
conspiracy theories.
Let's take a look at the tweet she sent out
where she responded to Joe Biden saying we've
got to go community to community.
We've got to go neighborhood by neighborhood.
We've got to go door to door and just say,
hey, do you want to get vaccinated?
Marjorie Taylor Greene tweeting, Biden pushing
a vaccine that's not FDA approved shows covid
is a political tool used to control people.
People have a choice.
They don't need your medical brownshirts showing
up at their door ordering vaccinations.
Of course, nobody would be ordering it.
They would just be making it really, really
easy to get one.
Hey, we're here.
You want a vaccine?
Here you go.
You can't force people to be part of the human
experiment.
And even that is sort of alluding to Nazi
medical experiments.
Come on, guys, come on.
And if you have forgotten or didn't see it,
this is Marjorie Taylor Green just a few weeks
ago, realizing that the Holocaust was really
bad and she was wrong to compare Nancy Pelosi
to the Holocaust.
OK, take a look at that.
Speaker 3: I always want to remind everyone
Unidentified: I'm very much a normal person,
and I think it's important for
Speaker 3: me to always be transparent and
honest.
And I just want to tell you all I'm really,
really lucky.
I was blessed with I am blessed with amazing
parents.
And my dad passed away in April.
But I will say he taught me some great things.
And one of the best lessons that my father
always taught me was when you make a mistake,
you sit down and I have made a mistake and
it really bothered me.
So I definitely want to own it.
This afternoon, I visited the Holocaust Museum,
the Holocaust, and there's nothing where it
happened.
Unidentified: You know, over six million Jewish
people were murdered.
More than that,
Speaker 3: there were not just Jewish people,
white people, Christians, all kinds of children,
people that that the Nazis didn't believe
were good enough and perfect enough.
And the horrors of the Holocaust are something
that some people don't even believe happened.
Some people deny, but there is no comparison.
And there are words that I have said for Mark
that I've made that I know are offensive.
For that I want to apologize.
And I am I am just fine and very glad to be
able to come out here and do that.
And I believe that if we're going to meet,
we need to be able to lead in a way where
if we messed up, it's very important for us
to
Speaker 1: say we're sorry.
So, you know, clearly her apology was insincere.
Clearly, this is a very, very sick woman.
Clearly, this is someone who just can't get
away from these comparisons, the Nazis and
the Holocaust and all of this stuff.
But there is sort of an interesting conflict
here because Marjorie Taylor Green is a massive
Trump suck up.
I mean, absolutely one of the biggest.
But she's constantly doing anti back stuff.
But remember, Trump said not that long ago,
quote, It's a great vaccine.
It's a safe vaccine and it's something that
works.
I recommend it to a lot of people that don't
want to get it.
And a lot of those people voted for me.
That was Trump saying that even recognizing
that there is lots of anti vaccine among his
supporters.
What would Marjorie Taylor Green, a massive
and bottomless Trump, suck up say about the
fact that her leader, Donald Trump, is saying,
hey, even the people who follow me and don't
want it, they should go ahead and get it.
And they're just continuing to push this type
of thing.
Here is Charlie Kirk, who sort of like a young
young Republican group leader of this group
called Turning Point USA, Charlie Kirk just
compared vaccination guidelines to apartheid.
But more than
Speaker 4: anything else, Tucker, what we
are going to do is a massive public relations
campaign and make sure students know they
are not alone.
They don't have to hide in the shadows.
All of a sudden they're concerned that if
they get the vaccine, they're going to be
treated as if there's there's something I
said this earlier and this is a big statement,
but it's almost this apartheid style open
air Hossan situation like, oh, you can have
your freedom back if you get the job.
This is unacceptable.
We're going to fight back against it.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So they just can't get away from this stuff.
What's interesting about the Charlie Kirk
thing is that I have been warning not as something
that we want to divide people, but as something
that is simply going to happen.
If you continue seeing such vaccination rate
gaps between Democrats and Republicans, between
liberals and conservatives, between Biden
voters and Trump voters, this is going to
turn into a Republican pandemic.
Now, of course, because the the the vaccine
is not 100 percent effective.
Even if every Democrat got vaccinated and
very few Republicans did, some Democrats are
still going to get sick.
You only have 92 percent protection, maybe
even slightly lower against the Delta variant.
We still don't know the level of protection
against the lambda variant, but there is no
doubt that that vaccination gap is going to
start infecting more and more Republicans
than it is Democrats if it's the Republicans
who overwhelmingly are refusing to go and
get themselves vaccinated.
So sort of inadvertently stumbling, Charlie
corrected across a mathematical reality that
if the Republicans are the ones who are not
protected, they're the ones who are overwhelmingly
going to get sick and they are overwhelmingly
the ones who are going to die.
Was Marjorie Taylor Green's apology sincere?
Let me know.
You can find me on Twitter at Dipak, but I
think the answer is obviously no.
I think it got to the point where even for
her level of tolerating, being critiqued and
criticized, she realized I should probably
apologize for this.
But then within days, really going right back
to the same analogies and allusions, the Nazis
and the Holocaust and Hitler, just disgusting,
completely disgusting stuff.
Let's take a quick break.
We've got a packed show for you.
We'll be right back.
Remember that the
best way to support the work we do is simply
grab a membership at join Pakman Dotcom, it's
painless.
It really, really is.
And you can sign up with the coupon code indictment.
Twenty one.
Yes, Trump CFO very powerfully indicted.
Sign up there and we will see you on the bonus
show.
Let's hear from some people, some of our viewers.
Via discord, you can join the discord at David
Pakman dot com slash discord.
Why don't we start today with Andrew from
Miami, Andrew from Miami.
You're on the air.
Oh, boy.
Andrew from Miami, you are on the air.
Where is Andrew, that's the real question.
Hmm.
No, Andrew from Miami